bonsoir
vous vous êtes déjà demandé
comment on a pu faire ça moi c'est une
question que je me pose depuis l'enfance
par exemple quand j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait eu l'esclavagé
je me suis dit mais comment on a pu
faire ça
ou alors quand j'ai lu oliver twist et
que j'ai découvert la violence de la vie
de ses enfants mais comment on a pu
faire ça les viols dans l'église
catholique lancé est le racisme
l'antisémitisme
comment on a pu faire ça oui je me
laisse souvent débordé par mes émotions
c'est un peu mon problème mais c'est
peut-être aussi une partie de la
solution c'est que je sais pas vraiment
me résigner tous ses états de fait ils
sont moralement horrible mais il
n'empêche pas la terre de tourner
c'est des questions de conscience
collective c'est à dire que ça prend du
temps de faire évoluer les consciences
collectives et de faire advenir le
changement comme on dit il faut laisser
du temps au temps
mais il ya un sujet qui défie cet adage
le réchauffement climatique et la
sixième extinction de masse
on sait qu'on n'a pas le temps
on sait qu'on n'a pas le temps tous les
rapports du giec nous le disent et
pourtant on n'agit pas pas assez on agit
quand même pas
du coup bas les gens qui ont une
conscience écologique ça nous rend
particulièrement schizophrène c'est à
dire que on n'arrive pas à aligner notre
conscience et nos actions est en fait le
monde entier est schizophrène en ce
moment vous avez remarqué par exemple
une croissance infinie dans un monde aux
ressources finies ça fonctionne pas ça
ne fonctionnera jamais ça fait 50 ans
qu'on sait et nos dirigeants continuent
de naviguer vers la croissance comme but
suprême c'est totalement incohérent
nos entreprises elles n'ont plus que le
mot et rse à la bouche et pourtant elles
n'ont jamais autant ému qu'en 2021 c'est
incohérent même nous les consommateurs
on est incohérent à 65% d'entre nous on
se dit prêt à changer radicalement nos
comportements de consommation pour
sauver la planète et pourtant à chaque
confinement on a fait exploser les
ventes de nutella acteur majeur de la
déforestation
c'est incohérent
et puis il ya eu une élection
présidentielle et le parti écologiste a
fait 4,6 pour cent des voix
le monde est fou
mais à vrai dire il l'a toujours été et
en fait ce serait complètement naïf de
penser que le monde a déjà été justes ou
sens c'est
d'ailleurs la cohérence il avait
beaucoup entendu ce soir
ça veut dire l'absence de contradictions
du coup vous voulez de la cohérence en
matière d'écologie
ben c'est la mort de la démocratie bah
oui moi je vais vous en donner une
solution cohérente au réchauffement
climatique on est deux fois trop sur
terre donc il faut supprimer la moitié
d'entre nous
c'est un peu comme vouloir résoudre le
problème du chômage en interdisant aux
femmes d'aller travailler ça fonctionne
mais c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on veut en
tout cas moi c'est pas vraiment ce que
je veux
alors comment on fait pour réussir la
transition écologique tout en préservant
un cadre démocratique
est ce que on veut une démocratie qui
détruit la planète où une tyrannie verte
chaud devant et d'ailleurs ça peut pas
être binaire puisque ce n'est pas
cohérent en fait j'ai pas si vous avez
remarqué que la mise en cohérence d'une
chose rang incohérent quelque chose
d'autre
du coup comment on fait pour roba donc
garder un cadre démocratique préserver
les droits de l'homme préserver la
prospérité économique des peuples est
réussi la transition écologique
en gros il nous faut une révolution mais
il faut qu'elle soit douce parce qu'on
n'a pas envie du chaos politique et en
même temps il vocation ge tout waouh
c'est chaud
les philosophes des lumières ont mis
plus d'un siècle à voir leurs idées
traduite en politique les cathédrales
ont mis des centaines et des centaines
d'années à se bâtir
nous on a quelques heures pour créer la
civilisation écologique bah oui pendant
que je vous parle il ya le sablier qui
s'écoule il ya la biodiversité qui
s'éteint il ya la planète qui se
réchauffe
alors comment on fait pour créer une
civilisation écologique en quelques
heures
oui c'est une question que je me pose
souvent qui m'obsède un peu dit comme ça
ça paraît colossal et vertigineux je
vous la corde
mais si on regarde de plus près il ya
quelques ingrédients il ya quelques
outils qui peuvent nous aider
tout d'abord il faut inverser nos
croyances
vous faites peut-être partie des 10
millions de lecteurs à avoir lu sapience
ce que nous dit ce livre c'est que
sapiens nous on se distingue des autres
espèces par notre capacité à créer des
fictions collective ces fictions elles
nous permettent de coopérer de
collaborer et donc de créer des
civilisations par exemple une entreprise
n'est qu'une entreprise parce que ya un
bout de papier qu'on a décidé d'appeler
statut juridique est une fiction
même la france s'appelle la france parce
que il ya des gens qui l'ont décidé je
sais pas trop qui leur met très bien j'y
adhère
en fait le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est cette capacité à créer des
fictions écologique positive ben oui
aujourd'hui on lit l'écologie à la
notion de sacrifice c'est sûr qu'une
civilisation où on s'éclaire à la bougie
on se lave une fois par mois ça donne
pas envie
par contre si jamais on n'imaginait
qu'on pouvait travailler moins
vivre mieux et même
remplir un peu ce vide vous savez ce
vide de sens qui est parfois en nous
alors ça donne un peu plus envie la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut diffuser
la civilisation autour de nous
il y à une révolution du pouvoir en
cours depuis 30 ans ces nouveaux
pouvoirs d'après l'expression de jérémy
evans ils permettent à des idées de
faire le tour du monde en quelques
heures
regardez il ya des milliers de femmes
qui se sont emparés d'un hashtag mis
tous et qui ont lever l'omerta sur les
la question des violences sexuelles est
littéralement révolutionné notre rapport
à ce sujet elles ont fait bouger la
civilisation
à même pas 20 ans greta tanberg a fait
le tour du monde et a créé un véritable
emballement émotionnel quoi qu'on en
pense
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
nous avons tous la capacité selon des
coefficients puissant et imprévisible de
changer le cours de notre civilisation
pour l'instant l'écologie c'est un peu
une patate chaude l'état l'envoi aux
entreprises qui l'envoie aux citoyens
qui la renvoie à l'état et tout ça forme
un triangle de l'inaction
moi ce que je vous propose cette sortir
de ce triangle est de devenir un des
bâtisseurs un des maillons de la chaîne
de la civilisation écologique ça peut
faire bouger une virgule comme
l'humanité on n'en sait rien
enfin et surtout la question du temps on
n'a pas le temps mais on n'a jamais été
aussi vite je sais pas si c'est juste
d'un point de vue de l'éthique
mais tous les deux jours ont créé plus
de données que l'histoire de l'humanité
dans la craie
c'est colossal à nous d'utiliser ce
temps à bon escient au service de la
transition écologique
tous ces ingrédients tous ces outils ce
sont des courses etc ans de la
révolution internet on est sortis de
l'ère industrielle dans laquelle nous
étions depuis deux sets et nous sommes
entrés dans une civilisation horizontal
qui demande à chacun de nous se
positionner et qui permet à chacun de
nous de prendre le pouvoir
oui peut-être que la veille du premier
discours degré d'attenberg il y avait
une jeune fille dans son lycée qui a dit
la même chose à ses camarades de classe
et qui a seulement influencé de trois
personnes autour d'elle on n'en sait
rien
alors et si on abandonnait la cohérence
et qu'on lui privilégier l'action
un temps qui ne trouve plus son sens
dans l'âme des hommes le trouve dans
leurs actions comme il peut disait
malraux
alors c'est à chacun de nous de se
positionner de chez pas changer la
mentalité de ses collègues changer sa
façon ses comportements et ensemble on
peut faire bouger une civilisation
nous sommes la culture
et nous sommes la civilisation
c'est là qu'est le pouvoir
et ça peut avoir des répercussions
politiques ça va avoir des répercussions
politiques
ça peut donner great attenberg ça peut
donner quelqu'un qui fait un ted ça peut
donner un boulanger qui change la
recette de sa baguette
vous vous souvenez des comment on a pu
faire ça du début de mon talk il en
reste plan comment on peut manger des
produits hors saison
comment on peut manger de la viande et
du poisson industriels élevés dans des
conditions terribles
comment on peut investir notre épargne
dans des projets climaticides
comment on peut voir autant de plastique
autour de nous sans sourciller
et comment on peut acheter à nos enfants
des jouets fabriqués par d'autres
enfants
la civilisation
l'écologie c'est comme l' esclavage
c'est une question de conscience
sa demande à chacun d'entre nous de
porter son regard de prendre conscience
sur des sujets qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui dérisoire mais qui nous
permettent en quelques instants de faire
bouger la civilisé sion je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]